[Music]
[Applause]
this is this is quite a surprise ladies
and gentlemen Ron Burgundy from the
Action 4 News team
[Applause]
hello Coonan hello Andy hi Ron good to
see you Ron good to see you I liked it I
like to keep my chops up jam with the
cats here you know these cats maybe ya
smoked a little tea afterwards see if a
little backstage cutie ends up on my lap
and then later that night she's playing
my flute and by flute I mean my turgid
penis that's why I'm here Ron we all
know what you meant we got it yeah
but thank you this is such a surprise
thanks for stopping by and can I can I
tell you Conan you and Andy are
outstanding broadcasters I mean it night
in and night out you guys get it done
thank you thank you very much
that means a lot I've got I've got one
small criticism and it's it's probably
something only a professional like me
would notice but Conan you look awful
[Applause]
what I look awful you look like someone
put a bright red fright wig on a
skeleton and chucked it out of a
helicopter really yes yes I'm being kind
right now let me give you some words of
advice why are your hair lady okay okay
fire your your makeup lady fire your gay
wardrobe man yeah and just go under the
knife okay okay go into your doctor's
office and point at your face and say
doc it's a page one rewrite that's just
chair that's very hurtful that comes
from the heart Andi you look great
don't change it say
thank you thank you I don't know what
you're doing but keep it up all right
Ellison so basically that's the idea you
came on my show to play the flute and
insult me that was the idea
no I actually have an announcement I
want to announce this to everyone here
in the Americas to our friends in Spain
Turkey and the UK including England that
as of Oh nine hundred mountain time
Paramount Pictures and myself Ronald
Joseph Aaron Burgundy have come to terms
on a sequel to anchor
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
there will be a sequel to anchorman
there will be a sequel yes gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]